bonjour ainsi c'est steve kaufmann
aujourd'hui je vais parler d'eux une
question que qu'on discute assez
vivement sur notre forum à link c'est à
dire est ce que les enfants apprennent
mieux les langues que les adultes
pour ceux d'entre vous qui ne
connaissent pas dit que c'est un site
web pour l'apprentissage des langues
on peut apprendre jusqu'à 28 langues
vous pouvez vous enregistrer
gratuitement pour en tirer profit
c'est mieux de devenir membres payants
c'est un beau coup davantage ce 10
dollars par mois
enfin normalement je crois on dit que
les enfants apprennent mieux
bien que j'ai lu récemment une étude
faite par la cendre for applied
linguistics aux états unis qui
prétendaient le contraire et si en
lisant l'étude il est évident il était
évident que les études et les recherches
qui soutenait l'étude était basé sur ce
qui se passe dans les classes dans
l'instruction formelle et il se peut et
je serais même d'accord que dans une
situation d'apprentissage formel dans
une classe
et quand on essaie essaie d'apprendre
délibérément une langue
il se peut que les adultes soit aussi
doué aussi capable ou même plus que les
enfants mais ce n'est pas surtout dans
les classes que les langues ça prenne
ce soir je vais assister à une soirée où
avait on va écouter monsieur matte
ferghana polski des rats masculine
stations de radio à moscou que j'écoute
depuis six ans ça fait partie de mon
apprentissage de la langue russe et
j'aurai l'occasion de rencontrer je suis
très heureux et puis là il y aura
peut-être 200 immigrants russes et je
sais d'avancé que la plupart devons
parler assez mal l'anglais
et surtout les plus vieux les immigrants
plus jeunes les 30 ans 20 ans à 40 ans
ils vont parler mieux et puis leurs
enfants ils vont parler presque sans
accent ou peut-être complètement sans
accent comme des natives on a les amis
par exemple un couple de chinois les
parents qui habitent ici à vancouver
depuis six ans les parents parlent très
très mal l'anglais presque pas alors
qu'ils comprennent un peu ils vont à
l'école d'immersion ne subventionne pas
d'immersion mais là à l'école pour
l'anglais l'a subventionné par l'état
ils vont dans leur poche parce qu'ils
sont très riches qui font pas de progrès
du tout alors que leur garçon qui a 14
ans donc qui est venu à l'âge de 8 ans
il parle anglais caminati par contre mes
petits enfants vont à l'école
d'immersion en français ici à vancouver
donc c'est tous des écoliers donc
anglophones qui apprennent leur cours de
chimie d'histoire de n'importe quoi en
français baho après 9 10 et 11 ans il
parle pas très bien le français
ils comprennent mais il ne parle pas
très bien qui je crois qu'un adulte
motivés qu'ils iraient à l'école
d'immersion pendant dix ans bah ils
parleraient mieux donc quelles sont les
conclusions
bon je crois que statistiquement enfin
si on regarde les immigrants éviter il
est évident que dans la plupart des cas
sinon tous les cas c'est les enfants qui
parlent mieux soit l'anglais espoirs
français en françois lallemand une manif
à n'importer langue d'un pays qui
accueillent des immigrants et pourquoi
parce que l'enfant n'étudie pas la lande
délibéremment l'enfant veut faire partie
d'un groupe
il veut devenir comme ses amis comme les
autres et c'est cette ce désir de de
participer de communiqué
d'imiter donc sans avoir de complexes
peut-être qu'il ya des enfants qui sont
un peu complexé mais pas autant que les
adultes et en principe je ne crois pas
que les enfants et critique beaucoup
d'hommes le nouveau venu là de chez paou
rats qui parle un peu avec un accent
parce que très vite y va c'est assimilé
il va parler comme les autres et surtout
l'enfant je crois qu'il est moins moins
portés à se douter alors que l'adulte et
a moins envie de faire partie de ce ce
groupe parce qu'il réussit les chinois
et les français voilà il vient avec tout
ce bagage culturel j avais même une
espèce de ego culturel il va pas lâcher
cela pour devenir même temporairement
devenir canadiens anglais ou quoi que ce
soit donc il ya ce resistance
cette résistance est par contre l'adulte
il se croit très intelligent dans sa
langue n'a pas du tout envie de paraître
un peu stupide
donc il a beaucoup de complexes
d'inhibition et c'est qu'en principe la
plupart des enfants n'ont pas donc les
enfants apprennent mieux parce qu'ils
veulent parce qu'ils y
ils ne sont pas des étudiants de la
langue ils sont tout simplement des
petits êtres qui veulent participer à
une autre société une autre culture avec
d autres manières et il veut limiter
tout ce qui fait partie de cette autre
société
mais s'il s'agit d'apprendre comme
devoir bas je crois que les ados les
adultes peuvent apprendre
mais je crois que l intéressant dans
tout cela c'est que dans la plupart des
cas les adultes apprennent mal qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait faire pour d encourager à
mieux apprendre de mon avis si je
regarde par exemple moi personnellement
et moi j'aime bien apprendre des langues
et aujourd'hui ils en parlent
selon enfin niveau 2 de compétences
jusqu'à douze langues
mais la première langue c'était pas une
langue étrangère puisque au canada le
français est une langue officielle mehr
à la première langue que j'ai dû
apprendre c'était le français quand
j'étais à l'école j'apprenais pas enfin
je pouvais réciter les verbes qui
prenait être ou avoir enfin etc
mais je ne pouvais pas parler mais c'est
à l'âge de 16 ans quand j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser thaïlande
quand je voulais connaître les gens les
francophones au québec parce que il faut
dire dans les années cinquante à mon
rien c'était deux villes la ville
anglophone et la ville francophone dans
qu'on avait très peu de contacts avec
les francophones mais quand j'ai à l'âge
de 16 ans 17 ans je dis oui ça
m'intéresse
la culture la civilisation les films la
musique le théâtre et cetera donc quand
je voulais communiquer et participer et
devenir commun alors l'apprécient très
vite j'ai pu apprendre et je crois que
c'est ça qui est important
l' avantage des enfants c'est qu'ils ne
sont pas là pour apprendre délibéremment
les verbes les règles etc
ils sont ils veulent tout simplement
participer ce communiqué plus on peut
imiter cette attitude des enfants
c'est-à-dire moins se soucier des
petites fautes etc et ce uniquement
seulement vouloir participer communiqué
communiqué devenir comme un bain
mieux on va apprendre et devenir comme
ça ne veut pas dire quand
qu'on quitte pour toujours sa culture
qu'on abandonne sa culture moi je parle
deux hommes
je reste ce que je suis je suis canadien
anglais lettera la plupart de mes amis
et cetera vient de mon milieu
mais je chaque fois que j'apprends la
langue le chinois le japonais n'importe
quoi j'essaie de devenir eux
je veux être chinois japonais français
et russes n'importe quoi et c'est ça qui
est important c'est ce que font les
enfants et je crois que les adultes
s'ils peuvent imiter cette façon
d'apprendre les langues
il vaut mieux apprendre par exemple dans
mon cas quand je commence à prendre et
langues
je vais surtout beaucoup écouter et lire
sur le pays la langue l'histoire la
culture et c'est pour que ça pénètre
dans mon cerveau et aussi parce que je
veux apprendre des mots et je veux
améliorer ma capacité de comprendre
c'est la compréhension qui est à la base
puis après quand je veux commencer à
parler par les avantages enfin pour bien
parler il faut beaucoup par les ssd
bilan mais je ne me soucie pas tellement
des détails de grammaire etc
au début pour écouter pour lire j'ai pas
besoin de beaucoup de notions de
grammaire mais après quand je veux mieux
parler etc
alors là je vais regarder les règles de
grammaire encore une fois que j'avais
regardé un peu mais sans bien les
pouvoirs m'a rappelé et ben je vais
regarder ça
mais là la deuxième fois où la troisième
fois la quatrième fois que je regarde
les règles de grammaire
j'ai déjà des points de référence parce
que j'ai beaucoup été écouté la langue
et même après avoir lu des choses assez
difficile je vais peut-être aller dire
des choses faciles où je connais tous
les maux mais justement pour pouvoir me
concentrer sur certains structure
certains points de grammaire qui me
cause des difficultés mais pour que je
puisse vraiment pénétré dans la langue
pénétrez dans la culture je ne me soucie
pas de mes fautes et je communique je
parle j'écoute je lis je veux participer
dans cette culture et je crois que ça
s'est un peu si on veut et c'est un peu
comme un procès de l'enfant l'enfant ne
va pas étudié les règles de grammaire
l'enfant veut comprendre veut
communiquer et voilà et je crois que
c'est donc pour conclure je crois que en
principe d'après ce qu'on peut voir les
enfants apprennent mieux mais je crois
que il ya les aspects de cette façon
d'apprendre qu'on les enfants que nous
les ados les adultes nous pouvons
limiter et voilà et c'est ce que je
suggère et d'ailleurs c'est un peu les
principes de base de notre notre système
d'apprentissage à link voilà merci et
j'espère que vous avez soit des opinions
contraires des commentaires des
questions n'importe quoi dit les mois au
revoir et merci